hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel move university in creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
on my website movie universe be calm
thanks and enjoy the video
okay so free fatty acids little
introduction and talking about their
properties first and foremost what are
they they are hydro carbon chains with
carboxylic acid groups carboxylic acid
groups so what's their function their
function basically is to be used as fuel
why is that well fatty acids are highly
reduced molecules they are electron rich
they have lots of carbon hydrogen bonds
and carbon-carbon bonds they in fact
they are more highly reduced they're
more highly produced than carbs
carbohydrates which is why they actually
yield more energy than carbs upon
oxidation another function of their is
that they are the building blocks for
various membrane lipids we'll see that
later in other videos on membrane lipids
so what does this mean though
hydrocarbon chains of carboxylic acid
groups what's that structure kind of
looked like well if you imagine R as
being some hydrocarbon chain and then
the rest of this here being a carboxylic
acid functional group this is a fatty
acid this is a general structure in this
R group of course can be any hydrocarbon
chain and I'll give a quick example in a
second but this thing is an acid right
and specifically this hydrogen here is
the acidic hydrogen which means that if
this fatty acid act as an acid gives up
its proton it will exist in this
conjugate base form and give this
carboxylate ion of course the H+ would
be out there okay now typically at
biological pH is this is what we'd see
carboxylate form and so what can this
actually kind of look like this R group
we just said is a hydrocarbon chain so
what can that look like here's an
example let's just make this I don't
know let's make it six carbon
so this is the first carbon here one two
three four five six carbons this is a
fatty acid that thing if we want to copy
and paste it copy pasted right at
biological ph's
it would exist in this form without that
proton like that okay now how long are
these changes usually we just denote it
as R here how long these chains usually
well they can be from four carbons long
up to 36 carbons long typically and
they're usually even-numbered right so
you'll see in nature typically fatty
acids will be like 16 carbons long 18
carbons long things like that even
numbers now how do we classify fatty
acids how do we divide them up well
fatty acids one of the primary ways
they're classified is they're split up
into saturated fatty acids and
unsaturated fatty acids so sometimes
these terms can be a little bit
confusing let me give you their
definitions first and I'll over discuss
why it's talking about saturated versus
unsaturated saturated fatty acids have
zero or no carbon-carbon double bonds in
their hydrocarbon chain so I've got I've
got one drawn here looks like this in
fact I'll remove the numbers for a
second so actually I'll show you I this
is a ten carbon long saturated fatty
acid between none of these carbons do we
have a carbon-carbon double bond we have
a double bond here between the carbon
and the oxygen but there are no
carbon-carbon double bonds in this
hydrocarbon chain unsaturated fatty
acids however have at least at least one
carbon-carbon double bond in the
hydrocarbon chain okay now
once you have a double bond in the
hydrocarbon chain you can either have
you can either have a cyst double bond
or a trans double bond and which is why
that's give me a further sort of
classification here you can have sis
unsaturated fatty acids and trans
unsaturated fatty acids and again I've
drawn a couple of them here draw a cyst
one here and I've drawn a trans one here
of course each of those is also ten
carbons long now between carbons 5 & 6
in both cases there is a double bond but
here this one is cysts and that this
group and this group the two large
groups on the carbons of 5 & 6 are on
the same side of the double bond that
causes it causes the chain to bend or
form this little thing called a kink
kink some people call it a bend whatever
same idea okay but with this trans
double bond the groups are on opposite
sides and so this thing ends up being
fairly straight pretty much like the
straight chain saturated fatty acid now
you might be thinking well why does it's
called saturated why's it's called
unsaturated why don't they have another
term that's a little bit more intuitive
that refers to these double bonds well
what they're saying here is that this
thing the saturated fatty acids are
saturated with hydrogen's so these
carbons have as many hydrogen's as they
can possibly have as soon as you put a
double bond somewhere there are less
hydrogen's so if we take for instance
carbons 5 & 6 here there are two
hydrogen's on carbon 5 & 2 car or two
hydrogen's on carbon 6 whereas over here
in both of these cases these only have
one hydrogen each hydrogen there
hydrogen there so they are not saturated
with hydrogen's they don't have as many
possible hydrogens as they could have
okay now there's another way to divide
up these unsaturated fatty acids and I
have it over here just roll back up a
little bit hidden away from you guys
so unsaturated fatty acids can also be
divided up into
these two things Musa and PUFA funny
actually
Musa was where my nicknames growing up
that's actually where the movie and
movie University comes from fun fact
okay so the UFA portion basically is
unsaturated fatty acid so we have a M
UFA and PUF a so the UFA is unsaturated
fatty acid the M refers to mono which
means one the P is poly which means many
so here what this division or this
classification is basically referring to
a monounsaturated fatty acid means
there's one carbon-carbon double bond in
the chain whereas polyunsaturated fatty
acids have two or more right two or more
carbon-carbon double bonds in their
chain okay now how does all that play a
role when it comes to melting point okay
so we got to think about van der Waals
forces or intermolecular interactions so
when I think about van der Waals forces
I think about the ability of molecules
to stack so I'll kind of describe what
that means this is a second but there
are two key factors when thinking about
stacking to increase van der Waals
interactions stacking increases van der
Waals interactions so let me just show
you here if I had a fatty acid that was
of this many carbons long and I had
another one next to it
I could stack them like this such that
the atoms are as close to each other as
possible alright so maybe I can stack
like that I can have another one here
and that'll look maybe a little bit like
that those negative charges wouldn't
actually be next to each other but the
idea is that these atoms would interact
and have these van der Waals
interactions so these carbons here what
would it be interacting these carbons
here would be interacting and they're
there and those would form temporary
dipoles that are these Vander Waals
interactions so hopefully that's not too
fuzzy from G chem but the idea is that
the more stacking we have the more Van
der Waals interactions that we have so
there are two factors to consider when
we're talking about this and one of them
is the chain length so an increase in
chain length will actually increase the
melting point of a fatty acid how is
that well if we have an increase in the
chains chains length that means we have
more atoms more atoms so if we have more
atoms we have more temporary dipoles
between these atoms which means we have
more van der Waals interactions more van
der Waals interactions more intelect
intermolecular interactions means that
it would be harder to break these
molecules apart which would mean a
higher melting point so just so I can
give an example of that
imagine call this example number one if
we have let's say a 1 2 3 4 5 6 carbon
fatty acid right and we stack some of
these 1 2 3 4 5 6
they have interactions between these
carbons and between the hydrogen's or
I'm just drawing it the hydrogen the
carbons here the hydrogen's of course
are implied but we have a certain number
of Van der Waals interactions but so
that's a 6 carbon fatty acid right so 6
carbon fatty acid but what if we had
that versus a 10 carbon fatty acid so if
we had 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 carbons and
another 10 carbons right so a situation
where we have more carbons means more
atoms right we'd have more of these
temporary dipoles between these atoms
it's not just more carbons right it's
also like I said more hydrogen's as well
but the idea is that this this longer
chain would have the higher melting
point okay now another factor that plays
a role is degrees of unsaturation and of
course unsaturation is talking about the
number of double bonds right unsaturated
fatty acids have double
now an increase in the number of sis
double bonds will actually decrease the
melting point now I had to put sis here
and you'll see why in just a second the
reason why is that if we have an
increase in the number of system bonds
recall that system bonds have these
little bends with these kinks which
means we have if we have more if we have
more system bonds we have more kinks or
more bends and this will actually reduce
the ability of fatty acids to stack so
we would actually have less stacking so
if we have less stacking that means less
temporary dipoles so it decrease in the
number of Vander Waals interactions
which means that these molecules would
be easier to break apart therefore
having a lower melting point so if you
imagine something like if you take an
example of a sort of say a fatty acid
that has let's just draw like this 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 this is 8 carbons here 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 yeah 8 and this is a system a bond
versus something that has 8 carbons but
it's a trans double bond 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
and even between the same number of
carbons let's just number these carbons
here this is carbon number 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
let's put the double bond even in the
same location right there between 5 & 6
so here we have a straight chain in this
trans double trans fatty acid over here
we have this kink so if we try to stack
more of these you can you could probably
see that that the ability to stack has
been reduced right if we just draw
another one basically right next to it
notice that these these molecules might
not be able to get in and you know the
atoms might not be able to stack as
nicely
as neatly as tightly right as as as they
can so if these interactions between
these carbons here right versus if you
have another one of these another one of
these trans fatty acids right next to it
that can actually stack probably a lot
closer right so if there's a double bond
there so you can you can see if these
could probably pack more tightly right
the trans fatty acids so so here those
are the two factors chain length and
degree of unsaturation so between these
two which one would have the higher
melting point this one would have the
higher melting point because of course
they have the same the same number of
carbons in their chain length but the
the the sis double bond here reduces the
ability of the fatty acids to stack
properly and therefore lowers the van
der Waals interactions and lowers the
melting point now it just so happens
that this is important because there are
fats that are fats that contain fatty
acids that have saturated saturated
chains tend to be solid and those that
contain so those are things like animal
fat like lard and things like that
whereas fat liquid fats like oils tend
to have cysts double bonds so I hope
that video was helpful thank you for
watching
yo if you found that video helpful don't
forget to like comment subscribe for
more content and if you know anybody who
might find the videos helpful then
please share with them Thanks happy
studying